дякую, дуже дякую,
шановні учасники конгресу
, для мене велика честь бути сьогодні тут, і
перш за все я хотів би подякувати
за всю підтримку, яку Україна сьогодні
отримує під час цієї жахливої ​​війни, е-е,
від вас особисто з конгресу
в  загалом, як республіканці, так і
демократи, ми цінуємо цю двопартійну
підтримку нинішньої
адміністрації США на чолі з президентом Байденом
та американського народу, також я хотів
би подякувати послу Карпентеру за
блискучу роботу його та його команди в
ОБСЄ з метою відновлення безпеки на
континенті
Гельсінкі  Комісія займається
безпекою та співробітництвом у Європі,
і я можу вам сказати, що немає жодної
іншої країни в Європі на континенті,
яка зробила більше для безпеки, ніж
Україна, тому що ми єдині та
перші в історії людства і на
даний момент єдині  нація, яка добровільно
відмовилася від арсеналу ядерної зброї, який
у 1994 році був третім за величиною у світі,
і ми зробили це з метою
нерозповсюдження ядерної зброї та
підвищення безпеки і те, що ми маємо
сьогодні, жахливий варварський напад
на нас і спроба стерти
Україну з карти планети
, щоб відновити міжнародну безпеку,
тому що це дуже погане повідомлення, яке ми
повинні відновити як  якнайшвидше
територіальна цілісність україни
сьогодні 21 наша окупована, а ми
сьогодні говоримо про окуповану
територію 21. це як австрія та
швейцарія разом і швейцарія
разом все як штат Міссісіпі
чи Пенсильванія, уявіть собі, там
мільйони людей і ця
територія  було ще більшим, на щастя, ми
звільнили його частину, м'ясник, європейський
ворог, ці імена тепер відомі
всьому світу, тому що після
звільнення ми знали про жахливі
звірства, вчинені в цьому передмісті
Києва російською армією, і я хочу дати
вам свідчення не від себе, а від  Цю
дівчину звуть Софія,
їй 14 років,
і
ви можете побачити, що це таке  росіяни робили
з нею, і я просто хотів би
прочитати те, що вона сказала,
я Софі, і я маленька українська
дівчинка, я втратив руку, моя мати і мій
улюблений кіт у м'ясниці, я одна з
майже 1000 дітей, які постраждали
в  руки мешканців Я прожив у
лікарні три місяці, і мене все ще
мучать фантомні болі, зараз я в
Римі, але я здригаюся від кожного звуку, і
я боюся літаків, коли хвилююся,
я не просто
моя неіснуюча рука  це болить, болить
все моє тіло, я катався на шлангу в
минулому житті, але я не знаю, чи зможу я зробити
це знову з однією рукою, мені потрібен
протез, коли я його ношу, фантомні
болі вщухнуть, і я навіть
зможу  я одягаюся, і я маю сьогодні
її цю
іграшку, одну з ваших улюблених іграшок,
цього коня, і я хочу запитати вас, як це
могло статися в 21 столітті такі речі
трапляються з дітьми та нашими дітьми, і
що нам робити, щоб цього зупинити, я хочу
подякувати всім  вас,
сенатора Кардіна, представника Коена
та ваших колег  він висуває
заяву про те, щоб подати у відставку визначення того, що відбувається в Україні,
як геноцид, тому що це
геноцид. Конвенція ООН про запобігання
геноциду чітко говорить,
що в другій статті є чіткі критерії,
що таке геноцид, і я можу просто сказати
вам, що сказано, що геноцид  означає
будь-яке це без цитування будь-які з
наступних дій, вчинені,
але, на жаль, в Україні не будь-які, але
всі вони вчинені вбивство
членів групи,
заподіяння серйозних тілесних або психічних ушкоджень
членам групи, ви можете це спостерігати,
Софія, навмисне заподіяння
групі умов  життя, розраховане
на його фізичне знищення в
Голландії, частково ви згадали марихуану,
яка була без опалення та
взимку, яка сьогодні без води, влітку
введення заходів, спрямованих на запобігання
народженню в групі та все
сексуальне насильство проти українських жінок,
яке  відбулося примусове переміщення
понад 200 000 дітей до росії з
метою зміни т  ідентичність спадкоємців і
робити з них росіян, це все, коли
Росія окуповує наші території
спочатку без них вони спалюють
українські книги вони знищують українські
пам'ятники і це теж чіткі
критерії геноциду, тому те, що зараз
робить Росія, є геноцидом і я запевняю  вас
і заохочують вас прийняти ці законопроекти,
які ви так люб'язно спонсорували та
представили, якомога швидше, і
конвенція про запобігання геноциду
говорить не лише про те, що є геноцидом,
але якщо є геноцид,
це відповідальність кожної країни
на  планета зробити все можливе,
щоб зупинити його якнайшвидше, тому
в українському випадку це означає дайте
нам зброю, тому що це єдиний
спосіб зупинити геноцид - це припинити цю
окупацію нашої території, і нам
для цього потрібна зброя  нам потрібні
ракети великої дальності, нам потрібні винищувачі, нам потрібні танки,
ми не просимо чобіт на землі, е-е,
ми не
просимо інших речей, ми зробимо свою
роботу самі, але будь ласка  допоможіть
нам із цим, забезпечте нам
це, і ми стежимо за нашим
місцем на планеті, я можу вам сказати,
коли ми виграємо цю війну разом
із Сполученими Штатами за вашої підтримки як
найближчого союзника, ми зможемо бути достатньо
найближчий союзник в інших частинах
планети, щоб запобігти таким речам, які
сьогодні сталися в нашій країні, ми обов’язково зробимо
це разом з вами,
нехай Бог благословить вас і Бог благословить Америку,
велике вам спасибі